okay I am back and I'm playing chess
nine sixteen I don't think I've done a
chess960 stream ever oh this will be new
we'll have no no relevance to openings
guy has I moved g4
well that prevents b6
oh let's just control the center lady
five right man let me think about a six
bishop a seven
let's play e5
thinking about chess960 is opening
principles still apply so like you still
want to control enter squares you still
want to develop your pieces I find this
to do this and then after Bishop b2 I'll
play c6
and try and get the upon center
he's preventing me
you
I want to try and find some harmony with
the pieces which isn't easy in this
position
play a five maybe
thinking about 84 and maybe Bishop a7 as
well as f2 is undefended
let me open up the chats in one moment
I'm gonna play g6 I'm okay if he
concedes the bishop air
but also know he's polo 1600 so I should
not have any problems with this game f4
is a decent move like rook f8 happy to
trade further
uh where is the chat he's playing pretty
well except he just lost upon ok I have
the chat open hello to elastic hold
first connector
you
this probably won't be a long stream I
am I'm in st. Louis right now and I've
only been streaming for just over two
minutes I probably won't complete this
tournaments it's a six hour long
tournament I've joined about halfway
through and I have to leave in give you
about an hour to
actually just over an hour as I'm doing
commentary at st. Louis chess club so I
have to rehearse
and twitch not sure what that's
referring to okay I'm gonna tack on the
the queenside
going for a for actually my rooks are
finding some some unexpected
coordination in this position III is a
normal move
I'm too to play a 3 or B or a take B 3 a
sack the rook
probably be
I'm what civilized miss retreats
completely for a Queen f6 looks nice big
Knights activating that mean I guess he
could he could play Knight takes e5
Bishop if I'd want a g5 Queen f2
hey things could get interesting
probably wasn't the best line for me
that my minor pieces are terrible
I love with it
acting challenges right now I'm playing
the the 960 field arena
I have no chance of getting in the
shield I just want to want to play some
chess without worrying about opening
theory but he wants to play Bishop to b6
Yuni seven Bishop c5 but he's really
weakening his queenside I can think I
can just take this
and I mean he can can win the rook on f8
if he wants
about the first commenter twitch likes
to pitch oh I'm I mean I apologize on
behalf of twitch nothing to do
hello to pH well 56 good to see you
now if I recognized that name
rook g2a bad move stopping mates
to sack my finger and play Rupp take a
two
it's probably a bad move because bishop
you
I could play Queen up3 problem is Bishop
d6 Bishop c5 is coming oh wait a minute
Bishop sees there should be six I have
Knight c7 there's nothing too much to
worry about
oh think I'm gonna play cleanup three
we were like it's such a strange piece
configuration I just completely forgot I
have this knight c7 move
this kidding not really hurts
you
don't know if I believe that okay I see
seven saving everything
um but my my minor pieces are still dead
his setup isn't that impressive either
but this rook is pinned
so maybe I'm just threatening TK - and
he's also flagging as well
hello axe villager good to see you back
thanks for watching the commentary the
other day
okay this guy's about to flag a beat
take a two should just joshing
but one queen is coming
clicking v2
you
or not
okay I want a game let's go back and
start another game wait what's going on
why is it not opening in this tab join
the game I was strange
uhh
okay it's a new position let me think
it's nice that Li chess gives you more
time to make the first move
t4 looks reasonable
let's play t4
like d4 and e4
plan
a bishop can develop to be for
Sonlight should come to g3 probably
I think I'll start with this is it's
only logical square for the night I want
to stay flexible
it's another flexible move
question is how to develop the business
probably Bishop b4 and maybe c3 Bishop
b3
or maybe at some point III Bishop f3
make the minor pieces happy all right we
should be four
oh you forgot my partner's name my co
commentator is Catarina nem Silva ooh
who joined me on stream though the other
night but you know last right now but
we'll be back together in just over two
hours
the time being I'll probably get like I
don't know or five more games before I
have to go
and I'm wondering am I like am i on the
top list for 960
be curious if I have anything to play
for
chess960 top 50 player that's nice I'll
have to maintain that
place III wait see three runs into a
five
[Music]
the e3
two tabs open that's why the game
started strangely a five happens anyway
I have to move back
expecting 84 because I want to play for
myself
if you place a four I'll probably play
like a bee
preventing him from playing III
otherwise okay for
makes me happy can I take a free pawn
knight c6 maybe not
you
what to do
we don't know what to do here
it should free
should be to be solid
at some point I probably want to Castle
kingside hello to the coos good to see
you back
clastic hold saw me at Friday during
Friday action
the club on Friday
two days ago
out soccer bishop
[Music]
okay I'm just going to play up three
as you should always play up three and
now the plan is queen f2 and castle
excited yes
maybe I can attack on the queenside or
something
to take him awhile to Castle kingside if
he wants to or not just gonna play this
next move maybe he'll give me the bishop
hair
yes guess who I am
oh we actually guess
action
promised I don't remember being there
Friday evening
I'm the Trigorin
and
you
wait no yesterday was round five
it was round core
this week is so hectic like I can't
remember any
I do
I'm thinking
lacy for
lines before he s okay
they went to chess club my talent for it
let's remain cool
yeah in person chest is a lot different
than online chess a whole different game
he's now officially wanting to Castle
kingside maybe I just got the bishop
hair
a position
open the position
forgive
I like this at five square for a night
or a bishop
I take on each seven years geez
good spare hello past pond 99
hello to Flash Gordon 22 doing well
wait is this can mask
you
wait a minute no I've played the last
two cold
wait I'm flagging to flag
you
this
I actually have to focus here I'm gonna
stop reading at the chat the time being
my microphone
Oh is my microphone being weird
am I like lip-synching
after this game
you
time
that
you
you
Oh what am i doing play this
you
you
I think I just have to talk closer to
the mic as it is somewhat condenser mic
okay now this is completely winning
this would better be weenie 3 is
crushing
[Music]
I could take with pawn
let's just take the rook
okay that was nice
are there still problems with the mic er
I just have to lean in closer
let me see I'll check the audio levels
box fixer now you see this thing
with it maybe
okay
settings filters
voice suppression
you
I think I changed everything back to the
defaults
our problems let me know I did realize
something was weird the other day when I
streamed hopefully it's not an issue it
than mic itself
back to tournaments
hey I broke the top hundred
I still have to guess who elastic hold
is
as canvas was probably cut the right
guess
you
be for a Polish opening
so actually could resemble some actual
chess position
um like this Bishop can develop maybe I
can play a London system I can play a
London system
this is so exciting
I'm so happy right now
oh shoot I lost a pawn
you can see that threats I guess I this
is only move
that was unintended and ce2 pond I guess
that's the thing about chess960 you can
like make threats against ponds on what
early
maybe I can trap his queen somehow
maybe not
leaf size
i disturb him
so he has some scarier threats
how you letting some funny line like a
take b4 h5 metaphor Queen take a chain I
take G to checkmate
but that's that would be too awful
that's why h5
that's it it's at least good to like
acknowledge that night take g2 is a
potential mates in some sort of
positions
you can queen 20:18 that's a new name
thanks for being me on YouTube
most of my YouTube videos are just
twitch streams that I archive but if you
have any feedback let me know this is my
first time doing chess960
on stream
do this in this in sack upon
go for peace activity
if you tell me in the video I'll
probably know
you remember most of the videos I've
done
I can take on before and then take on a
two maybe
and he's gonna play Roque one and I have
to play Queen c4 and things are getting
traded maybe if he wants to trade Queens
can completely obliterate my pawn
structure by taking on c4 them taking on
f6 but the Queen i3 makes me happy
maybe 994
please play e3
pigs on the seven it's gotta be
it's gotta be Ashish rights
she's
the rating matches up
I would be my top guess
I feel like we played on me chest too
what am I doing here tonight take G to
King f1
93 check to queen g4
his night has no squares there you could
play like rook h3
I'm going to be safe
yeah I guess the sheesh
um because that's
that's all I remember from that video
look I guess it could be conversed
but no and west would not make any sense
my rook is trapped okay I have to focus
because I'm currently losing the
position let's take the pawn
you
and maybe deep
I guess correctly I think
um
but my position is terrible
you
okay I have to focus hundred bits to
give me motivation here
good news is if he does take on b8 his
Queens out of play
and maybe I got some comp maybe d4 Queen
g2 doesn't really do anything
he's also attacking the bishop
you
you
I mean the strategy is to play quickly
key pieces on the board and trying to
flag him
eat things complicated if 100 bits every
time you're able to up mean up for three
don't even know what that means
okay
you're able to be a queen up for more
than three moves
look I'm currently a ruck down so that
doesn't really help
aku's with a 200 bits thank you buck
who's let me not get distracted let's
play b6 cutting off his queen
I mean I'm technically up a queen here
because this queen is out of play
if you have a queen that's not doing
anything you still have a queen
yes I have to retrieve my g6
and this increment it's going to keep
him alive
look for how long I like this e5 move
this is nice
now maybe six
I think the cleaning lady's here I might
I might say hi to someone very soon
let's play this
I'm is of the essence it's not trade
Queens
it should be five on the horizon
or not
don't know what to do
uncomfortable position
you
he's about to flag though
hey fired I ran a
you know stay in st. Louis uh through
the twenty-something until the end of
the tournament because I'm doing
commentary every day so they have to do
tournaments I leave town
okay back to tournaments perfect so far
that was a close one
thank you everyone for for giving bits
as to call them Baku's
the youth stream
I will say streaming has helped me in
various ways that keeps online chats
interesting was for a while I was
playing online chess and just got boring
but when you have an audience to play
for it can keep things keep things
interesting it also holds me accountable
to not not be too lazy
a poor idea okay tempted to berserk this
guy but I'll see it's not bezerk
I'm as precious
if any ponds which are not defended
he does not
I don't like when the bishops are in the
center that's hard for them to actually
develop harmoniously so play play a
Queen's pawn opening in this case it's
the Bishop's pawn opening
but the bishop on this diagonal
develop in some weird way
such a deserving victory I don't think I
deserve to win that last game but that's
life
wanna take
you'll play e5 just open the center
because he has no nothing developed and
this is a principle in normal chess too
when you're more developed it favors you
to open the center
keep developing
and my next move I'll have all my minor
pieces developed
I will be at Chicago open but I'm not
playing
but I realized that in order to play a
tournament like that I have to be very
well prepared I have to be in good like
physical and mental shape and after
doing commentary for nine days in a row
it's going to be
it's going to be difficult to like be in
the best shape but I'll definitely stop
by
with bishop
a feeling that's a plunder
and then take care
I don't think you can take back because
f5 is
on looking
I've never done a meet-up before
um because I don't think my my audience
is big enough but if I were to do me
that it would probably be the chess
tournament
but it's not like that's not my
it's not on my immediate to-do list
I'm play g6 I want to play f5 but it
would be cool like doing me that place
I've considered it like when I travel
internationally because I do get
messages from all over the world
way more about you hate fast games it's
okay to prefer a slower chess it's still
possible to get low games online
but if you hate something sometimes you
have to
at least try it so you hate it a little
less
it's it's a element of chess where you
like you're you're low on time and you
have to just deal with the pressure deal
with the using your intuition
I'm drinking a relief bTW
courtesy of the st. Louis chess club
okay I'm gonna play 94
the bishop I could Castle queenside
right
how do I do it like that
to do if you return to I'll be cool I
just don't have time this week but maybe
like in the evening at some points
I don't think I've actually hosted a
tournament
ever maybe I did once I
Norm's I do not I was close a couple of
times
ah closest I've been was Chicago open
2015 I needed to win the last round I
had a +5 position and I drew was so sad
I think if not online dual commentary
with John Bartholomew I mean that would
be cool I am looking to do more
collaborations with other streamers
or youtubers
Bartholomew has some contract with chess
calm but I don't mind streaming on chess
calm I'm happy to stream on on any
platform though yeah definitely in the
future I think next week I'll do some
some dual stream with crew 64
as there will be at Chicago open there
will be a lot of people in Chicago
other people to meet up with
trap in the petrov um it should be
archived on YouTube somewhere I forgot
which video I should do a better job at
labeling the videos
if you want to clip this I can just tell
you the notation you can go back and
like play through the moves be 45 Knight
f3 Knight f6 I take e5 and I take e for
Queen e2 Queen e7 Queen take E or
be 64
up on take it on take night Pontic and
then you you play the Bishop Bishop f4
g5 Bishop g3 f5 and black wins apiece
I hope I didn't intrude out there
it's hard to like say notation
completely unrelated to the game that
I'm currently playing
okay so this is just a positional end
game up upon it's going to take some
I'm technique to win this maybe just
some flagging technique a gray Hatter
with the 216 bits
great hazard element answer your message
like you sent me a message at some
points I forgot to answer the cargo open
is
[Music]
a few days straight in five days
or for days
depends what schedule you play
this is actually not easy to win because
he's blockading on dark squares
I'm not sure if I can break through I
break through on the Kings side or the
Queen side they see five
and then maybe I play a five
and fix both pawns on light squares
I actually do want to analyze this
because after it take taking c3a 5 was
my plan and I thought that he can't
really do anything yes to wait
I would put my bishop here let's say he
can continues to wait
plan was going to be to eventually bring
the king here and play g5 it should be
winning this King side down I should
have some breakthrough on the
inside
I said night up three two times iPad
okay well I'll just show it over the
board I can't show it in a chess960
position study
[Music]
devote this to Petrov
amazing Patra okay I spell that
correctly is it a beer two F's
um
hello
Oh is an endgame
those injuries actually looked over that
like triple pawns okay let's let me just
show this real quick I'll get very
minimal commentary this is a trap where
if white plays incorrectly black can win
material
Bishop f4 is a bad move because g5
bishop g3 f5 this is the line if you
want to analyze this further you can
just click the link in the chat and
there's a study and people in by around
with it and you can use the tools in me
chest like you could use the opening
explorer
there hasn't been too many games
from
masters I'm sure there has been games on
me chess in this position everyone plays
Bishop g3 almost everyone and then f5
so it's a useful trap to know I forgot
who asks a question but I hope your
you're satisfied
anyway let's play one more game
I mean I'm top 50 actually I don't think
I've gained too many rating points so
I rush
960
I've gained 20 points
I'm sure there's other studies on me
chess or her better than the one I just
created okay so this pawn is undefended
and this pawn is undefended that's
important to identify
what to do like to attack on the
kingside
I mean whenever there's a night in the
corner I feel like you have to start
with my cheat which I bring my towards
planner
I'll just develop tonight's first
we're actually going to have something
that resembles some alkyne as you could
play e5 and then Knight c3
or not
clever move
in the night
they say you shouldn't move the same
piece twice
early in the game how do you move this
night three times
but it's okay
my my position
this is a move
as Queen a6 Bishop e7 Queen zj7 rotate
the queen is trapped
you
what to do
a p5 a meeting
my p5 is kind of funny
I just play ace
you
I play Bishop e2
a six
you
range position he hasn't developed
anything yet
or aggressive I'll start with this
Evans expected
you
do continue packing
you
wanna play queen c4 made him on c7
he doesn't have too many options here
six looks awkward for him
maybe playable
let's redevelop the Knights
and maybe the plan is to do some some
more night maneuvers I don't know what
I'm doing
but I'm trying my best
you
this looks really interesting actually
because if I
I mean whatever he does I can dig on a
seven erté kanji six
this might just be crushing ignite 86
you
and then I can dig on b7 next and beat
up material I am sipping some sweet tea
pure leaf
at least that's what I want you to think
it's actual truth
um oh it's his move
you
you
this is probably going to be my last
game so if anyone has questions before I
go make yourself heard otherwise I'm
probably going to be back in the future
yes I still do have to this
Buffalo rook of the bishop error this
pawn can't be defended
I could Castle kingside or queenside
the Summer Classic starts at 1:00 p.m.
Central Time every day a broadcast
starts with 3:30 Central Time
so 90 minutes until darts and pause the
tournaments
show a few lines in the Carroll Kahn is
black I'll show one line well compromise
originally I didn't want to show any
lines in Carroll County but we'll
compromise on line
um
what to do
buddy
we'll just call this caro-kann trap
uhh
line
I will show the only variation of the
caro-kann that sort of inspired me to
play the caro-kann now I've never
actually played the Carol Collin in like
serious games but after seeing this I
was someone inspired so we'll look from
black side very weird to transition from
chess960 back to like normal chess or
just feels bizarre well let me show this
c6 we'll stick with this mainline big
tick
and now the most common move here for
black is Bishop f5 and there's a lot of
theory which honestly doesn't excite me
too much for either side but if you're
just like starting out you want
something simple something maybe easier
to play I can recommend this move Knight
f6 where the main line is after take
take black has easy development and I
don't know it's
I think it's easy to pick up without not
without knowing too much so there's a
cool trap that I would like to show from
this position where boy doesn't take on
that six but plays the substandard or
suboptimal night to g3
uh study of philosophy okay I'm not even
gonna wrap my mind around that question
uh so after Knight g3 Black has a very
strong move on each five
preparing a simple pawn h4 and the night
on g3 actually becomes a bit awkward
I guess White has a couple options here
white could play H or himself but then
it's weakening to g4 probably black as
Bishop g4 and is happy so there's this
cool line probably cooler for black is
after Bishop g5
I can play h4 still let's imagine that
white-white wants to get the Knight to
e4 so the ignores in light for the time
being takes on f6 with idea that if
black takes either way then Knight will
come to e4 so in this position black can
take on g3
so there's just two traded pieces and
now wife will play the move Bishop to e5
and this brings us to the key position
and before I go any further I actually
would encourage people who like want to
get good at just actually try and solve
this position for black let me make this
a mainline
this is black to move and win material
I've showed that shown this to a number
of students some students find it's
somewhat quickly some students really
struggle with this it requires a pretty
unusual idea
messy Marvin might have some idea but I
I'm debating whether just to leave it
here and let people try and solve this
I'll give you guys some time maybe I can
go back and look at if there are any
questions
study of philosophy ever lead to answers
are simply more questions
no comment and no answer for sure
philosophy yeah if you want more time
you can pause the stream
[Music]
but very soon I will I will I guess show
this I don't want to leave you
okay so messy Marvin already suggestions
adjusting some lines
let's imagine ripped a gauge to Brook
take h2 on take h2
bishop th and this is this is kind of
the problem the bishop defends each do
the x-ray vision
um
so as black you might have some ideas
but it's all about finding the the
proper execution
great hugger is suggesting Queen a5
and then f2 so there is a line here
let's imagine Queen 8/5 Queen d2
then black is crushing after Pontic f2
but after a queen a 5.85 like in place
c3
if you take on f2 King jig f2 I mean it
looks nice for black but it's just
Hayden White's King is okay
Oh re chalky
eh too
I will say it's not enough just to find
the first move
to solve this position you actually have
to like calculate some forcing line
messy Marvin saying Queen a5 sacked the
Queen for the bishop and then rogue h2
that's the hf2 saying 25 c3 rotate
should be 5 do
okay uh let me just say black to move
immaterial okay I'll go ahead and show
it because it looks like a couple people
found it
yeah few people found it messy Marvin
you you have the exactly the right idea
just a wrong move order after Queen
eighty-five check
III taking on e5 would be a mistake
because it you're losing a queen and you
actually don't have a forcing
continuation after that so move order is
important that after c3 then you take on
each to rook take h2 and now the amazing
Queen to e5
and then plant a g5 on Ziggy - and
you've given up a queen but you're
guaranteed to promotes is like can't
offend again it spawn in each two
so it's a beautiful line lots of
variations being suggested in the chats
if I'm not mistaken
I guess black could play rook tickets to
first
it also worked for tickets to rotate h
225 check
if I check is better to start with
mm tick
mistress transposes
I've never had this in the game but we
can we can check the database
anyone anyone play this ever hey this
has been played ten times on me chess
a birthday gate shoe is played between
85 check was played but white one
oh because white or black took on e5
right away which is not good because
after rook take a true white doesn't
have to take back on h2 and light will
be up a queen
um named masters games
no masters
um so yeah it's kind of a rare trap
because white maybe wouldn't go into
this Bishop g5 mine but it's still
called cool to know hopefully it gives
some inspiration always nice to at least
know the potential traps in whatever
opening you play
you
oh you clips the Petrov trap I probably
said that wrong might want to not trust
that clip anyway I'm gonna end it there
because commentary starts in just over
an hour if you guys want to watch me do
commentary with with Catarina and i'm
sylva you can watch on the st. Louis
Chess Club YouTube channel
hello the ancient gamer I'm sorry
disjoined I'm not going to be able to
stick around for much longer
let me rate someone Akshay Chandra still
streaming I think he's in st. Louis I
didn't see him recently though good
thing he's in town
thus in a new tab
let's where did I go Oxshott Chandra so
rain
Chandra not giving him probably won't be
giving him too much viewers but there we
go
I do not use Linux I'm just on a MacBook
I just use whatever it's called OSX
um anyway uh raid akshay andhra bye guys
I'll see you in the future or I'll see
you in an hour
I do commentary maybe feel free to join
the YouTube chat I